whoa did you know that so much plastic
is drifting out in the ocean that it has
made a giant island 2 times the size of
Texas you think I could like make a
resort on it hey what's that it's this
old video game system that dad insisted
made him a hardcore gamer I'm pretty
sure it just makes him old what's it
called super maleo brothers hey it's not
working
precise electronic that would surely fry
if the slightest bit of liquid meets it
try blowing on it that logic seems sound
okay Louie VC let's go save the princess
Oh Mamma Mia princess you're supposed to
start in the castle not this time Molly
oh now I'm leading the adventure we VC
that moats you from sidekick to third
wheel Oh Mamma Mia
no a VC lose stop it we have bigger
concerns this finale' is up to no good
again Oh No what is he doing now
he's decided to build himself a new
castle made entirely out of plastic
without any concern about what that will
do to the environment you know how he
does it
tons of hard plastic spikes molten
plastic motes go-cart track all that
stuff but how does using plastic hurt
the environment
wait don't you guys know anything about
plastic oh when you grab it you become
invincible for a short time nope that's
the Stars oh no of course not
what did I expect from two guys who
constantly hit bricks with their heads
anyway you guys need to know everything
about plastic to defeat this van our
let's start at this finale's plastic
Factory
Hey what are they doing that's how
plastic is made fossil fuels such as
crude oil and natural gas are heated
causing them to break down into small
molecules called monomers
these monomers can be combined to form
long chains called polymers and these
polymers are plastics
hmm but I thought that the fossil fuels
are used to to produce energy that's
also right even this factory runs on
energy from fossil fuels and all this
use of fossil fuels greatly contributes
to pollution in our environment Louie VC
we've got to stop this
good job let's go now
yeah what do we thought two distinct
outs that's all dioxin boo Lucian and
with everything bisphenol Tsar has been
doing it's getting really bad dioxin
ablution what's that
dioxins are highly toxic chemicals
released into the atmosphere during the
production of the plastic polyvinyl
chloride also known as PVC dioxins can
cause many health problems let's get out
of here I think that I would rather
fight peaceful now sir then breathe in
this bull ocean
whoa that's a lot of plastic what you
don't I'll do any heat this must be
where bisphenol A is disposing of his
plastic waste
you mean he's just gonna leave it out
here most likely yes many commonly used
plastics are not biodegradable meaning
that they don't break down over time
instead they're going to stay here
forever in bacteria and fungi such as
those mushrooms are decomposers meaning
that they can break down matter some
fungi and bacteria not that particular
mushroom can even decompose a small
amount of some types of plastics but
it's not enough so mushrooms are really
helpful yes and that's why you guys
should stop eating so many of them
well at least plastics can't do any harm
by just sitting out here actually they
can toxic chemicals can accidentally
leak out of the plastics and into the
landfills and eventually into the
groundwater
what's toxic in the plastic chemicals
like BPA and phthalates BPA is used to
make clear polycarbonate plastics and
epoxy plastics that coat the insides of
food cans BPA is an endocrine disruptor
meaning that it can interfere with the
hormones in our body and phthalates are
chemicals added to plastics to improve
flexibility and durability like BPA some
phthalates can also cause problems to
the endocrine system while others can
cause cancer once these chemicals into
the groundwater they can be easily
absorbed by plants and they can also
enter rivers lakes and oceans come on
I'll show you
what's wrong with those these animals
have been getting their water and food
from this BPA contaminated pond just
downhill from the landfill just like in
humans BPA contamination will cause
reproductive problems in plants and
animals and this gets worse higher up
the food chain first small organisms
called plankton absorb tiny amounts of
the toxins from the water then when fish
eat hundreds of these plankton they
absorb the chemicals in each one this
magnification process happens again when
the animals eat these fish once in the
organism the toxin is very hard to get
rid of so it just accumulates inside the
organism Oh No what should we do about
the landfill we could burn the plastic
actually that's a bad idea
burning plastic greatly pollutes the
environment by releasing toxic chemicals
into the atmosphere
well then we better to stop bisphenol
Sir
oh no got a joke in
look at all these plastic yes many
plastics especially plastic pellets
often end up in oceans these pellets are
especially harmful to fish because they
are easily mistaken for food once eaten
the pellets block their digestive system
and they die we've got to defeat
bisphenol sir
hey what's over there in the ocean it
looks like a floating pile of trash
that's actually all plastic every year 8
million tons of plastic is put into the
ocean that's equivalent to 5 plastic
bags for every foot of coastline in the
world who dares enter my plastic Kingdom
it'sa me Mario and Luigi see I feel like
you are borrowing this from someone else
oh look at bisphenol Czar's healthbar
whoa
he looks like this van Hauser has been
poisoned by all that drastic bisphenol
ZAR probably ingested the BPA dioxins
and phthalates that the plastic released
into the air and water
that did it sure but those chemicals in
the air water and ground will take
longer to get rid of even a small impact
from plastic pollution can cause a large
problem in the environment what can we
do to help you should avoid using
plastic when possible bring a reusable
grocery bag use your own takeout
containers and carry a reusable bottle
for drinks and if you have to use
plastic make sure you know where to
recycle it yep so what do you guys want
to do now do you want to play tennis
no how about go-karts yeah what about
soccer
no let's just throw a party